des jeunes commencent à sortir dans la
rue
Elise décide de bloquer le centre-ville
et de canaliser les supporters une
semaine auparavant pour le match aller
les situations à dégénéré il y a eu 42
interpellations
[Musique]
alors ça je vous le fais pas dire vous
avez été complètement idiot mais c'est
idiot aussi Messieurs ça s'appelle une
infraction pénale
[Musique]
vous cherchez quoi vous cherchez à
rallonger votre détention c'est ça
quand vous rentrez dans la salle de
Topsy que vous avez deux corps posé et
quand vous êtes effectivement une jeune
femme vous avez les vieux briscards du
commissariat de la gendarmerie qui
attendent une chose c'est que vous
tourniez de l'oeil faites attention à
vous le plus important c'est que tout le
monde revienne en bonne santé et qu'on
n'ait pas de blessé à l'issue après on
verra ce qui se passera ok allez bon
courage à tout le monde
[Musique]
le commissaire la Commissaire je laisse
faire je la substituteur je trouve que
c'est pas très beau une substitue si
vous voulez prendre le féminin on va
vous dire elle est féministe vous prenez
le le ah bah oui mais elle préfère
singer les hommes et rester dans une
appellation plus masculine alors
choisissez
[Musique]
maison d'arrêt de Luynes
ici 730 détenus sont en attente de
jugement ou purgent leur peine
tous des hommes
[Musique]
et c'est une femme Elisabeth bortolin 43
ans divorcé et mère de deux enfants qui
depuis deux ans et chef de détention de
cette prison
tous les matins le même rituel se faire
ouvrir huit portes et 4 grilles pour
atteindre son bureau
on a encore ils traînent
[Musique]
et tous les matins il faut gérer les
incidents qui se sont déroulés pendant
la nuit aujourd'hui un détenu qui a été
frappé par d'autres prisonniers
on a un petit souci
nous créer un petit souci je crois
quel problème dites-moi un peu
incident et voilà je voudrais recharger
au premier franchement j'étais bien
c'est juste ce gars là et après ils sont
venus à trois dans la salle d'activités
vous cogner sur la tronche il m'a
regardé travers il va mal parler et bim
ça repart ça on n'en veut pas donc pour
votre protection pour le calme le vôtre
et celui de qui avec qui vous avez eu
souci et bien voilà il y a une mesure
qui est prise aujourd'hui on vous
demande de changer de cellule
oui mais juste s'il vous plaît me mettez
pas au rez-de-chaussée parce que en fait
c'est pareil ça va être même pire dans
notre promenade ça permet d'assainir une
situation après on revoit on fait le
camp ensemble dans peu de temps et on
peut réajuster ça marche à plus bonne
journée de même Elisabeth dirige une
équipe de 162 surveillants
tous les jours il faut gérer les
arrivants c'est un peu de l'hôtellerie
il ne faut pas mélanger les primaires
qui ne connaissent pas l'univers
carcéral et les habitués correct quand
même perdu respectueux des personnels
c'est toi Didier qui l'a vu non c'est
toi il faut tenir compte du caractère et
de la dangerosité de chacun des nouveaux
venus
profession coiffeur ça peut être
intéressant et il a 36 ans qui peut
l'absorber en primaire
tu prends
le suivant il a 40 ans il est primaire
également
réservé
il est non fumeur très important
affectation sur le bâtiment C en attente
en attente de travail
[Musique]
connu reconnu sur connu 150e
incarcération j'ai travaillé travailler
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut qu'on
les aie face mirador
à Luynes ils sont 128 tomes et 34 femmes
pour surveiller les détenus
alors ça fait quoi d'avoir un chef femme
[Applaudissements]
pour travailler dans l'administration il
faut avoir du caractère et les femmes
qui travaillent elles ont autant de
caractères que les hommes voilà c'est
une question de caractère enfin moi je
peux au début c'est vrai quand je les ai
vu arriver il y a une quinzaine d'années
j'en doute
je pense que j'ai plus doute au début
les surveillants hommes étaient un petit
peu réticents par rapport à votre
arrivée
c'était plutôt à la cuisine à faire à
manger pour pour le mari
[Musique]
c'est en 1993 que les femmes sont
autorisées à travailler dans les prisons
pour hommes
[Musique]
une nouveauté difficile à accepter pour
certains anciens de la pénitentiaire
nous en tant que Nana nous étions de la
chair fraîche et si on avait le malheur
d'être à plusieurs à déjeuner entre nous
et bien nous étions obligatoirement des
lesbiennes et si on avait le malheur de
boire un café avec un collègue en ayant
refusé le café à un autre nous ne
pouvions être qu'une [ __ ] entendu
on va se faire là sur le mouvement
promenade un petit contrôle les détenus
frappent les portes de leurs cellules
c'est l'heure de la promenade
de la prison les détenus sont jeunes et
s'impatientes
par contre
un moment particulièrement tendu pour
les surveillants
elisabeth a décidé de faire un contrôle
surprise on commence par le front de la
les lumières les télés sont éteintes la
semaine dernière ils ont découvert des
téléphones portables cachés dans les
chaussures vous laissez la chaise en
cellule
[Musique]
on a des gens de plus en plus difficiles
en face de nous des capsies de plus en
plus donc beaucoup plus de violence et
complètement inattendu
bonjour gars qui vous a dit bonjour
bonjour surveillant tous les jours de
façon bien
à un moment donné surveillant vous la
porte il se prend un pain et on sait pas
pourquoi si on n'a pas une notion de
solidarité d'entraide on est on est
foutu quoi
je regarde le temps que vous mettez
alors que vous devriez être prêt plus
que prêt voilà
la veille ça se met et oui
au fur et à mesure les chaises n'étaient
pas détruites quand on les met en salle
d'activité ça irait mieux d'accord
c'est terminé
pour aller chez le médecin pour être à
l'heure dans 9h30 regarder dans 10
minutes vous avez rendez-vous allez on y
va
allez-y
pour ne pas attiser les tensions
elisabeth a élaboré une méthode tout
faire pour ne pas élever la voix sans
faire de concession en avoir rencontré
dans la rue vous avez été chiante et
pénible
vous nous avez cassé les pieds
parce qu'il fallait que la cellule soit
aérée que il y a rien en fenêtre et ben
vous voyez maintenant je travaille je
machin je me lève tous les matins je
fais comme si je fais comme ça ça veut
pas dire que c'est ce qu'ils ont appris
à la prison heureusement si on peut leur
donner un petit coup de pouce tant mieux
mais
loin de moi ce genre de prétention mais
ça leur permet de un moment donné de
d'hortilité
mais cette méthode est parfois difficile
à appliquer pour certains détenus
9h30 c'est déjà passé il est 9h44
comment on fait
regarder comment ça se passe maintenant
si vous arrivez en retard là-bas il y
aura pas de problème puisque c'est de
notre fait et vous devez non de notre
fait et c'est comme et vous serez pris
de toutes ces façons
de discuter vous passez pas
vous aurez d'autres moments pour y jouer
[Musique]
jeune homme vous cherchez quoi là
vous cherchez quoi
vous cherchez quoi vous cherchez votre
détention c'est ça
de par votre attitude
on vous parle mal est-ce que moi je vous
ai insulté
je l'ai pas dit
[Musique]
l'intervenant ce soir petit dîner à la
maison avec des collègues de la
pénitentiaire
[Musique]
Elizabeth est divorcée et ses parents
viennent souvent lui donner un coup de
main
[Musique]
mais c'est toujours bon quand les gens
ils reviennent c'est que c'est pas
mauvais
vous imaginez votre petite fille quand
vous avez trois quatre cinq ans l'âge de
vos petits-enfants aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous pensiez qu'un jour elle serait
dans cette profession c'est à dire à
l'âge de 10 ans oui
je me pensais ça parce qu'elle découpait
tout ce qu'elle pouvait trouver sur les
prisons parce qu'elle disait toujours on
a des choses à faire en prison on peut
aider et quand elle m'a dit qu'elle
allait dans la pénitentiaire j'ai bon
ben c'est tout c'est son choix c'est
tout même très dur comme métier et
surtout pour une femme
vous pensez que c'est pas un métier de
femme
mais il faut voir
la volonté bon je
sais que
mais moi je voyais plutôt un homme dans
les prisons
de carrière est-ce qu'elle a changé un
peu endurcie c'est tout et c'est le
métier qui le veut parce qu'elle envoie
de toutes les couleurs alors elle ne
peut pas s'attendrir sur chaque chose et
puis il faut trouver une solution à tout
et voilà pour elle
elle sait comment dire elle s'est
blindée
je suis moins dans la compassion machin
si si je suis comme ça tout le temps
mais attends je moi je crève quoi j'en
crève
il y a des audiences qui me font
malotries au boulot et après tu peux pas
prendre toute la misère mais j'ai besoin
quelque part aussi de cette protection
pour pouvoir être bien avec mes mouflés
quoi c'est plus important sortez la
cuisine ça suffit
palais de justice de Bourg-en-Bresse
[Musique]
Marie-Christine Tarare est procureur de
la République depuis 22 ans
aujourd'hui le tribunal se réunit pour
une séance de correctionnel en
comparution immédiate
et à tous les symboles de la loi ici
bien entendu la République puisque on
rend la justice au nom du peuple
français ensuite la barre où les gens
s'expriment et puis le tribunal surélevé
la distance entre la barre et le
tribunal et je me souviens d'un
magistrat qui disait que
cette distance là c'était justement la
distance la distance de la vérité la
distance de la réflexion
mais il y a une originalité pour ce
procès à part le prévenu il n'y a pas un
seul homme
on a aujourd'hui une composition
totalement totalement féminine avec en
plus une greffière et deux avocats l'une
en défense et l'autre comme participe
avec un prévenu masculin et deux
victimes masculines c'est un peu
particulier on l'a pas on n'a pas fait
exprès
il y a des personnes qui font des
bêtises
commettent moins d'acte de délinquance
que les hommes ça c'est une réalité
une femme procureur une avocate de la
défense une avocate de la partie civile
et la présidente et ses deux assesseurs
et le jeune homme mis en cause pour
violence en réunion à l'encontre de deux
frères
une histoire d'homme une bagarre qui a
dégénéré après une course poursuite en
voiture
conséquence des cours reçus les deux
victimes ont perdu connaissance
quelle justification vous pouvez quand
même nous donner sur ce déchaînement de
violence
tout au début par rapport à sa posture
et la mienne
un peu
je les ai presque pas frappé en fait
c'est qu'une fois que en fait il y en a
un qui a attrapé l'autre là j'ai bien
deux trois coups en fait
des
en fait une fois qu'on était dans la
bagarre donc on savait pas que ça allait
terminer jusqu'à là qu'on s'est vraiment
pas qu'ils étaient dans un état comme ça
quoi
maître Dino je vous donne la parole pour
les victimes aujourd'hui il y a des
conséquences il a été détecté notamment
par le docteur qui pourrait y avoir une
commotion cérébrale et en tout cas un
hématome et qu'il faut des examens pour
savoir si il y a pas un danger vital
pour voilà on en est pour une histoire
de ta voiture et plus puissante que la
mienne c'est enfantin mais les
conséquences sont gravissibles
alors en effet de violence en réunion
effectivement dont vous êtes saisis
d'effet extrêmement gras cela a été dit
par la partie civile on a véritablement
des flaques de sang qui ont été
constatés sur la chaussée ce qui
démontre la violence des coûts qui ont
été portés sur les victimes c'est pas
une hypothèse d'école monsieur que de
voir des gens comme vous un jour
comparaître devant la cour d'assises
parce que les coûts qui ont été portés
ont été portés avec une telle violence
que finalement et bien la personne on
est décédé et après c'est un peu court
que de venir à la barre et dire je
regrette je ne l'ai fait exprès et je
pensais pas que ça irait jusque là parce
qu'on ne sait jamais monsieur ce que la
violence peut entraîner ce que la
violence peut générer donc en répression
des faits qui sont reprochés à Monsieur
je retire à son encontre une peine de 18
mois d'emprisonnement dont vous pourrez
à sortir une partie d'un sursis de
l'ordre de 10 mois ces victimes seront à
indemnisées et de la manière la plus
rapide et la plus complète possible très
bien je vous remercie maintenant
[Musique]
pendant le délibéré
petit regard féminin sur un délit
typiquement masculin
c'est pas quelqu'un qui
aurait des tas de procédure en cours
c'est pas ça du tout non mais je pense
qu'il y a effectivement cette espèce de
petite
intolérance à celui qui a celui qui
c'est vrai c'est typiquement
dans les jeunes générations pour les
places de varie ça ne va pas au-delà
finalement que ta voiture elle est
beaucoup moins puissante c'est-à-dire
que nous les voitures on s'en fiche un
peu quand même le frère de l'accusé lui
regrette que le tribunal soit
exclusivement féminin
d'abord représenter le peuple
le peuple parfois que deux femmes
devrait avoir notre devrait être mixte
c'est vrai qu'elle est lois après une
interprétation des lois qui n'est pas
pareil par des hommes la femme tout à
l'heure il y avait l'avocat qui a rigolé
quand on a parlé des
caractères des hommes un peu qui qui
frime un peu en voiture elle veut que tu
as rigolé alors c'est vraiment très bien
qu'il y a une différence entre les
hommes et les femmes
vous pouvez vous asseoir l'audience et
reprise
le tribunal vous reconnaît coupable des
faits qui vous sont reprochés en
répression vous pendale à la peine de 20
mois d'emprisonnement dont 8 mois a
sorti d'un sursis avec une mise à
l'épreuve pendant deux années
le condamné par directement en prison et
devra purger un enferme
pas plus sévères je pense que c'est dans
l'imaginaire des gens peut-être qu'il y
a je sais pas 50 ans 60 ans quand les
premières collègues ont commencé
peut-être à arriver dans ce milieu
d'homme elles ont peut-être été obligées
de de jouer un peu je sais pas moi de se
masculiniser un peu pour pouvoir se
faire respecter je sais pas mais qu'on
soit homme ou femme c'est vrai qu'il
faut éviter de se le bus en tant que
magistrat de se projeter ou de
s'identifier aux victimes et au prévenu
c'est pour ça que la différence elle
s'estompe entre un homme et une femme
magistrat 10h30 ouais une différence qui
s'estompe et pourtant donner aux femmes
le permis de juger n'a pas toujours été
une évidence
sauf exception les femmes d'une part
sont inaptes à exercer nos fonctions
d'autorité d'autre part nuisent aux
prestiges du corps judiciaire
ainsi s'exprimer dans un rapport
officiel le substitut général de la cour
d'appel de Paris en 1955
9 ans après que la première candidate
soit autorisée à devenir magistral
très vite les femmes utilisent cette
possibilité d'appliquer des lois écrites
par des hommes pour juger une majorité
d'hommes elles sont déjà 123 en 1955
représente 45% de la magistrature en
1992 et sont aujourd'hui majoritaires à
exercer ses charges lourdes les femmes
ont été autorisées à rentrer dans la
magistrature en 1946 c'est-à-dire juste
après la guerre il y avait eu plusieurs
tentatives auparavant pour les faire
rentrer mais bon qui échouait toujours
parce que on disait que les femmes
n'ayant pas les droits politiques ne
pouvaient pas être juges être juges
voilà à partir du moment où il y a eu
des femmes ont été admises il fallait
surtout qu'elle se conforme à ce qu'on
attendait d'elle il y a même une des
femmes que j'ai interviewée qui était
rentré justement dans mes structure soit
dans les années à la fin des années 40
et qui me disait que elle avait su
qu'elle était intégrée
dans dans la magistrat enfin que ses
collègues l'avaient vraiment accepté le
jour où il l'avait appelé mon vieux
moi quand j'ai commencé à travailler il
va encore des vieux gendarmes donc
certains avaient tendance à ne pas du
tout écouter ce que je pouvais leur dire
cette espèce de truc ouais c'est une
femme forcément bon elle a pas forcément
tout bien compris quoi
c'est vrai qu'il y a des choses que je
comprenais pas forcément bien parce que
j'étais pas chasseur et quand on me
racontait des affaires de chasse ou je
comprenais peut-être pas tout à fait
comment ça s'était passé mais il y a des
tas d'hommes qui vont pas à chasse et
qui aurait pas plus compris que moi quoi
bon enfin moi j'ai souvenir dans mes
premières années de fonction
d'avoir été de permanence et d'avoir été
appelé à transporter sur les lieux
d'intérêt et donc des parties comme ça
du tribunal
avec une tenue vestimentaire qui était
certainement pas adaptée pour l'endroit
où j'allais dans une cour de ferme avec
de la boue partout bon bah quand vous
êtes avec des petits escarpins petit
tailleur etc bon alors c'est vrai que
les gendarmes avaient un petit sourire
entendu
provoquant un peu de substitut qui était
là avec ces petites chaussures et qui
savaient pas trop mettre les pieds et ce
qui m'a valu quand j'ai quitté mon
premier poste de de substitut et que
j'ai été nommée procureur de recevoir
comme cadeau de la part des gendarmes un
treillite gendarmerie donc je pense que
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'aurait pas
fait un homme par exemple voilà donc
mais ça m'a ça m'a servi parce que je
j'ai eu l'occasion d'utiliser voilà
être femme complique-t-il ou
facilite-t-il les auditions
ont-elles la main plus lourde ou même
des réflexes sexistes priorité aux
femmes
ce matin Marie-Christine reçoit dans son
bureau des prévenus qui ont reconnu les
faits pour des délit mineurs au terme de
l'audition Madame le Procureur pourra
proposer une peine sans passer par la
case correctionnelle
premier cas de la matinée une toxicomane
connue des services de police elle s'est
fait contrôler au volant en état
d'ivresse
et vous aviez avec vous en plus une
bouteille de whisky dans la voiture
pour vous tout allait bien
preuve que ça n'allait pas bien
vous aviez presque 3 g d'alcool dans
votre organisme et ce matin là est-ce
que vous avez bu quelque chose avant de
venir là
vous êtes sûrs
[Musique]
ne changez pas une dépendance par une
autre donc que ce soit que ce soit
compliqué que ce soit difficile que ce
soit douloureux j'en ai conscience hein
c'est sûr mais maintenant il faut
impérativement madame que vous preniez
conscience que vous vous mettez en
danger vous mettez en danger les autres
et qu'il faut réagir qui font réagir
votre vie et les pâtes terminée
vous avez du potentiel
on oublie tout on oublie tout et on
serait jugés
en tout état de cause il est jamais trop
tard pour réagir madame
je peux pas vous proposer une peine de
principe parce que c'est très grave et
je pense que la gravité de la sanction
elle doit vous permettre de comprendre à
quel niveau de gravité était votre
comportement d'accord alors moi je vais
vous proposer donc à titre de peine une
peine de 5 mois d'emprisonnement a sorti
d'un sursis avec mise à l'épreuve
pendant une murer trois ans ça veut dire
que cette peine d'emprisonnement vous ne
l'effectuez pas si pendant trois ans
respecter les obligations qui sont mises
à votre charge et parmi les obligations
que je mets à votre charge c'est
l'obligation bien entendu de suivre et
de poursuivre les soins que vous avez
entrepris pour traiter votre problème de
dépendance et moi je vous propose une
annulation de ce permis de conduire avec
une interdiction de le représenter avant
l'expiration d'un délai d'une année
j'ai 28 ans j'ai 10 ans de permis j'ai
jamais eu un accident j'ai bien sûr j'en
ai pris conscience j'ai toujours
respecté
une prévenue qui ne fait preuve d'aucune
agressivité pour une peine qui sera
facilement acceptée
pourtant être procureur c'est souvent
être confronté à des personnes violentes
il y a des détenus qui arrivent ici qui
sont relativement dangereux le fait
d'être une femme ça vous défavorise pas
moi j'ai un peu le sentiment que
justement parce qu'ils sont face à une
femme ils vont pas être dans cet
affrontement dans l'agression dans
l'insulte dans
et que quelquefois on voit des
procès-verbaux on lit que les les gens
ont été extrêmement injurieux enfin bon
on dit des choses et quand ils arrivent
dans le bureau ben la plupart du temps
c'est bonjour madame enfin si on sent
que quelqu'un s'énerve vraiment s'énerve
à ce moment-là moi j'arrête je dis à
l'escope on va vous le redescendez
monsieur quand vous serez calmé on
recommencera mais on s'arrête là voilà
Roubaix
la numéro 2 du commissariat central est
ici une jeune maman de 30 ans
[Musique]
a fait Science Po et du droit pénal
avant de réussir le concours
[Musique]
d'études pour avoir le droit d'enfiler
la tenue réglementaire le gros blouson
hiver
ça peut apparaître comme un peu difforme
pour une femme je veux bien le
reconnaître donc ça c'est la tenue de
service général qui se porte donc
toujours dans tous les cas avec le gilet
par balle
pour les chaussures bah c'est les types
Rangers quoi super féminin
[Rires]
et pour les grands jours il y a aussi la
tenue de prestige
donc là il y a une distinction qui a été
faite entre les hommes et les femmes de
distinction donc la jupe du plomb
qui arrive au genou et le chapeau ce
qu'on appelle le tricorne
à chaque fois faut adapter les cheveux
voilà donc ça c'est le tricorne et qui
est spécifique pour les femmes comme ça
donc là il y a
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le commissariat est mobilisé
pour une mission à risque
Élise a convoqué ses équipes pour le
briefing
bonjour une femme qui dirige 350 hommes
une image très éloignée du mythe qui
fait de la police
un métier d'homme
il faut se départir un peu de cette
image macho dans la police quoi on est
plus c'est pas les films des années 70
avec Belmondo son blouson en cuir et le
pétard à la ceinture loin de ça on a
affaire à des pères et des maires de
famille donc les modèles jointe et c'est
la première fois que les gars sont
commandés par une femme et moi je trouve
que le passe très bien quoi bonjour à
tous pour ceux que j'ai pas vu donc pour
ce soir même dispositif exactement que
lundi
idem croix Saint-Pierre l'équipe
d'Algérie rencontre l'équipe d'Egypte en
match retour pour la qualification à la
Coupe du monde de football à l'issue de
la rencontre des incidents pourraient
éclater les
ventes à emporter
alcool et kebab les snack ou autre
magasin donc valable à compter de 16h
jusqu'à minuit quand vous voyez un
établissement qui est concerné et qui
n'a pas fait ce qu'il y avait à faire et
qui n'a pas fermé ou verbaliser vous
faites fermer et vous l'annoncer sur les
ondes faites attention à vous pas de
blessés le plus important c'est que tout
le monde revienne en bonne santé et
qu'on n'ait pas de blessés à l'issue
après on verra ce qui se passera ok
allez bon courage à tout le monde
[Musique]
Marie-Louise fille Meyer a connu
l'époque où il n'était pas évident pour
une femme de commander un service de
police
ce n'est que dans les années 70 que les
femmes sont admises dans les concours de
gardiens de la paix puis d'inspecteur et
enfin de commissaire
femme flics et pas trop c'est toujours
le même problème est-ce qu'on peut être
les trois à la fois après plus de 30 ans
de service à l'heure de la retraite
petit souvenir pour Madame le
Commissaire Divisionnaire en arrivant à
l'école c'était aux femmes de s'adapter
à une profession qui était
plutôt masculine qu'on le veuille ou non
donc ça traduit bien l'orientation et la
perception des choses que l'on avait à
l'époque puis on n'était pas nombreuses
certaines manquaient pas de pensée qu'on
était la Libye éventuellement
dans une dans un métier d'homme
Marie-Louise prend son premier poste de
commissaire à Strasbourg en 1978 elle a
25 ans et dirige une équipe
exclusivement masculine quand on arrive
on vous regarde il y a le bouche à
oreille qui a fonctionné auparavant
il y a des filles qui arrivent enfin
vous voyez bien qu'on vous regarde un
peu quand même comme une bête curieuse
parce que les femmes inspecteurs à cette
époque on les trouvait dans les Brigades
des mineurs dans les services de
délégation judiciaire mais relativement
peu dans des services j'allais dire
extrêmement opérationnels ou très
dynamique on a été naturellement
prudente probablement plus attentive
plus à l'écoute plus observatrice et
n'hésitant pas à prendre des conseils
auprès de nos anciens
aujourd'hui presque 25% des postes de
commandement dans la police sont
attribués à des femmes
panier requin 45 ans est déjà 24 ans de
métiers derrière elle vous nous suivez
commandant elle est chef de l'unité
sécurité et proximité de
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois en banlieue
parisienne
elle gère 86 policiers donc un spam et
pour les patrouilles elle veille à
équilibrer les effectifs selon les
interventions c'est bien qu'on ait une
femme dans les brigades 2 pourquoi pas
et 3 ça deviendrait peut-être un peu
critique dans le sens où on pourrait se
retrouver un jour un équipage de femmes
et ça peut-être sur les interventions
c'est pas forcément souhaité ne
serait-ce que pour les rapports de force
ce matin opération chien renifleur dans
une barre d'immeuble à la recherche de
stupéfiants
annie a grimpé tous les échelons de la
hiérarchie un par un d'abord simple
gardien de la paix elle a passé tous les
concours internes pour devenir officier
en 1994
elle a tout connu la police en tenue la
BAC et la brigade des mineurs flic une
histoire de
passionnent service courir après les
voleurs en fait tout ça c'est quelque
chose qui me qui m'a passionné
[Musique]
c'est vrai que 1986 on disait la police
on ne dit plus mais pour moi je pense
être à ma place faites les pelouse parce
que c'est c'est de là qui jette en fait
vous faisiez quoi dans les étages
à temps plein mais une vie privée à
temps partiel
annie a longtemps fait passer sa passion
avant toute chose
[Musique]
je suis resté célibataire en certaines
temps pour dire bon j'avais une vie mais
je m'impliquais pas dans une vie
familiale pour
et de couple pour pour pouvoir préparer
mes concours et m'investir parce que
j'avais à une époque de ma vie c'était
ma priorité peut-être le seul regret que
j'ai c'est peut-être la parenthèse qui a
fait que je n'ai pas d'enfants
aujourd'hui mais bon moi je mets ça sur
la vie
c'est une touche maman
sont un peu différentes des jeunes
hommes quand elles seront
le même dynamisme et la volonté que les
gars
peut-être plus il faut démontrer
c'est bon il y a des femmes sur le
terrain qui excusez-moi monsieur mais
qui tiennent plus la route que certains
gars mais on n'est pas des garçons pas
forcément messieurs messieurs messieurs
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez messieurs
heureusement
vous tombez sur des violences conjugales
mieux vaut une collecte féminine pour
contact d'une victime que nous elles
vont avoir plus le contact et nous on
n'est pas à l'aise du tout
visiblement
on va dire
la poupée je joue au pistolet pour moi
c'était vraiment donc pour moi c'était
un rêve
allez on contrôle on contrôle on
contrôle c'est du systématique
mais je crois qu'une femme doit en faire
davantage il faut qu'elle en fasse plus
qu'un homme il faut qu'elle fasse le
petit quelque chose de qu'elle soit plus
attentive qu'elle soit plus à l'écoute
des gens qu'elle soit peut-être plus
disponible parce que indiscutablement il
y a une comparaison qui se fait les
collaborateurs vous compareront
inévitablement un commissaire de police
homme
retour dans les rues de Roubaix le match
Algérie Égypte se termine dans un quart
d'heure tout est calme
Elise la jeune commissaire est au
téléphone avec son mari d'accord
de 19h30 apparemment des mineurs qui
avait des bonnets de péruviens à tout à
l'heure oui tu es encore là
donc je te disais le troisième tiroir
en bas voilà c'est ça bon allez à tout à
l'heure OK
bon appétit d'accord ok ça marche à tout
à l'heure
c'est normal
et puis voilà puis l'autre côté c'était
pour faire le point sur les
interpellations
fin du match on arrive à proximité
l'Algérie a gagné trois à deux
jeunes commencent à sortir dans la rue
on ferme les points de cisaillement on
va fermer tout parce qu'il y a trop de
véhicules qui se rapprochent Élise
décide de bloquer le centre-ville et de
canaliser les supporters
une semaine auparavant pour le match
aller la situation à dégénérer il y a eu
42 interpellations
[Musique]
donc interpellation de la personne qui a
projeté au g de piles sur les militaires
de l'OGM donc il montait actuellement le
véhicule de la BSU
petit débrief adjoint en mer inquiet
[Musique]
police
trois interpellations plus tard les rues
de Roubaix se vident ou finale une
soirée plutôt calme
policière procureur ou surveillante de
prison elles sont fans de loi leur
quotidien est d'appliquer et de faire
respecter la loi
31e chambre c'est en dessous la dixième
Catherine Charles elle aussi est une
habituée des prêtres et des prises mais
de l'autre côté de la loi celui des
femmes compagne ou mère de détenus
aujourd'hui Catherine se rendent au
palais de justice de Paris elle connaît
bien les lieux elle va assister à un
nouveau procès de son fils Christophe
cette fois il est poursuivi pour avoir
transmis en prison un rouleau de scotch
au braqueurs Antonio Ferrara un acte
anodin qui pour la justice pourrait être
le signe d'une évasion en préparation et
un procès c'est aussi l'occasion
d'apercevoir son fils un fils qui ne
serait libérable qu'en 2045
condamnez une première fois à 50 prisons
en 1989 alors qu'il est encore mineur
Christophe Khider enchaîne des peines
toujours plus lourdes
6 ans 1997 et surtout 30 ans pour
meurtre et volamin armé en 1999 pour un
braquage de convoyeur de fond qui a mal
tourné
[Musique]
en 2001 il tente de s'évader de Fresnes
avec un code détenu à bord de
l'hélicoptère trois complices dont son
frère Cyril la belle échoue et un
gardien grièvement blessé Christophe
Khider est de nouveau condamné cette
fois à 15 ans de réclusion
et puis en février 2009 il remet ça
profitant d'un parloir il s'évade avec
un complice de la prison de Moulins
une cavale de deux jours
qui finit sous le feu de la police et
une balle dans le poumon
aujourd'hui à 38 ans Christophe Khider
est l'un des 10 détenus les plus
surveillés de France
après 6 heures de procès Catherine
Charles ressort de la salle d'audience
une nouvelle peine et quelques années en
plus à attendre
deux ans et demi
ça fait 30
+ 15 là ça fait 45 + 3
[Musique]
48 + 2 et demi 45 et demi
on tombe dans des dans des voilà des
chiffres encore une fois de
science-fiction tu as vu
Catherine comme après chaque audience
est entouré par les membres de
l'association harpie qu'elle a créé pour
sortir les longues peines de l'oubli
un quotidien chaotique mais un cœur de
mer indestructible dans la crainte
permanente d'une mauvaise nouvelle bien
sûr c'est grave ce qu'il a fait le
dernier parloir où j'avais été m'avait
il m'avait dit maman elle était
extraordinaire la mère du jeune Imbert
tu sais cette femme qui a l'euthanasié
son fils et moi je comprenais pas je
disais mais oui bah de toute façon elle
a abrégé ses souffrances mais je sais
pas ça doit être terrible je sais pas
moi je pourrais peut-être pas faire un
truc comme ça et j'ai saisi toute
l'importance il m'a dit ben c'est une
mer extraordinaire imagine-toi un fils
qui peut plus gratter qui peut plus rien
faire et qui te demande aide-moi à
mourir c'est le plus bel acte qui soit
et tout ça ça m'est revenu il est en
train de me dire
s'il se passe quelque chose
fractacceptes que que je préfère mourir
plutôt que que que tu me gardes vivant
pour ton confort affectif ou moral
[Musique]
la maison d'arrêt de Lyon Corbas où est
emprisonnée Christophe killer permet aux
familles des détenus à l'isolement de
leur apporter à l'occasion des fêtes de
Noël un colis de 5 kg
alors Catherine pour l'occasion a mis
les petits plats dans les grandes
barquettes
ça c'est rillettes de saumon fait maison
faites maison par Francine
là on a un émincé de bœuf
mariné
et des accras de crabe et c'est
vachement important que un mec en tôle
donc mon fils en l'occurrence Christophe
il puisse aussi avoir un repas bien plus
qu'amélioré exceptionnel
la tendresse la tendresse la tendresse
bordel alors c'est impératif en prison
que les crevettes soient décortiquées et
contrairement à la légende on peut pas
rentrer d'orange en prison faut le
savoir ni de clémentine d'accord donc
c'est vraiment un mythe on peut ramener
voilà que des produits cellophasés mis
sous vide et transparent parce que nous
nous sommes tout doit être transparent
même une orange pourrait cacher une arme
ou un explosif
dans les barquettes ça perd de son
cachets forcément mais je suis
particulièrement content là elles
viennent de le faire je vais aller le
mettre au frais et il leur a demain donc
c'est super
8h du matin direction Lyon pour le
parloir de Noël
tous les mois Catherine fait la route
pour voir son fils
10 heures de voiture dans la journée
pour 45 minutes à passer avec lui
le bon anniversaire au bout du fil son
autre fils Cyril
après avoir purgé une partie de sa peine
pour la tentative d'évasion il est
aujourd'hui en liberté conditionnelle
voilà je vais dire à Christophe que je
t'ai eu que tu l'embrasses
tu fais des kilomètres de route Olivier
m'amène mais
tu le fais en train ça veut dire en
train la prison elle est pas à côté de
de la gare donc elle est à excentrée à
30 ou 40 km pas du tout pratique d'accès
donc tu imagines les contraintes
que financières
morales parce que ça joue sur le moral
tout ça c'est un but quoi c'est de
déliter le lien familial
depuis plus de 15 ans que Christophe est
en détention sa mère lui a toujours
rendu visite de prison en prison
si j'étais une petite chose faiblarde
peut-être il serait pas debout comme ça
aussi ça oblige à se dépasser quand on a
une maman qui voilà qui qui se laisse
pas abattre par
par la fatalité enfin par le fatalisme
ambiant
je veux des chaussures dans le coffre je
mets des chaussures j'arrive pas comme
une racaille de cités quand même c'est
bien non non non non non
que je ressemble à une maman un peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnellement pour Noël le parloir
a duré une heure trente
fatigant
et ça faisait un moment là que je
l'avais pas vu enfin ouais c'était pas
vu c'était un peu c'était un peu
il a des plaques sur le visage
l'isolement quoi
les nerfs tu te parles il est super
calme et tout son corps bouge et en
mouvement sans arrêt c'est horrible
épuisé après chaque mois
de 15 ans que ça dure
il fait beaucoup de sport tout ça mais
dans une salle et c'est pas suffisant il
me disait j'ai envie de rien pour parler
de son état il nous a dit
c'est comme un athlète
qui se prépare pour une compétition
et une compétition qui aura jamais lieu
puisque
quand tu te mets en forme comme ça c'est
pour la vie en fait et il a il a
certainement conscience que il y a pas
de vie après ça
bien évidemment que je suis une maman
donc
même si ça va j'encaisse c'est c'est
toujours douloureux voilà
de sentir impuissante face à la à la
souffrance de son enfant
[Musique]
retour à la prison de Luynes
pour sa tournée du matin une mauvaise
nouvelle attend Elisabeth la chef de
détention pendant la nuit un détenu a
tenté de mettre fin à ses jours
[Musique]
les morts par suicide 115 rien qu'en
2009 sont la hantise des surveillants
à l'hôpital
[Musique]
ils sont trop bon les filles un suivi
c'est malheureuse on le vit comme un
échec mais on le vit en plus comme
[Musique]
on a en plus un sentiment de culpabilité
parce qu'on est tellement à nous
demander des explications sur beaucoup
beaucoup de choses comment ça s'est
déroulée où on était comment etc
qu'on finit par culpabiliser allez on
est parti
[Musique]
allez-y je vous en prie le plus grave
les suicides les bagarres ou les vols
[Musique]
mais aussi le quotidien comme les
retards sur les colis
autant d'événements qu'Elisabeth doit
résoudre au plus vite pour éviter que
les tensions ne sont venus entre ces
hommes enfermés parfois pour de longues
années
on est parti
alors pour les anciens comme cette
habitué de l'univers carcéral l'arrivée
des femmes en prison a été une vraie
révolution
tout début la première fois que j'ai vu
une femme c'était à la maison d'arrêt de
Nice et je me toute ma vie c'était une
blonde et une belle femme en plus
je suis pas resté choqué mais je suis
resté interloqué parce que la porte le
matin et je vois cette femme
qui dit mais je rêve
voilà c'est
marquant quoi c'est quelque chose qui
reste je crois que c'est très très
important que le métier ce féminise
parce que la femme c'est la femme et ça
restera toujours la femme c'est sûr ça
apporte un peu de douceur ça porte un
peu de
bienveillance rien que le parfum d'une
femme le parfum
c'est très important le matin une femme
vous ouvre la porte de votre cellule et
vous sentez ce parfum passionnant
quelques-unes qui mettent du parfum et
souvent du très bon parfum
je sais pas ça
ça apporte quelque chose à la journée
disons voilà
[Musique]
au revoir
au revoir la maison
[Musique]